HANAN YOUSSEF: Hello, everyone.
My name is Hanan Youssef
and I'm a product manager
on Google Compute Engine.
Today I will be sharing
with you an overview
of our virtual machine
offerings and how
they can help you run your
applications effectively,
efficiently, and
seamlessly on Google Cloud.
I hope that after
this session, you'll
be able to identify the
different options that
are available to
you on Google Cloud,
and that you'll be able
to leverage them to run
all of your workloads on GCP.
Let's get started.
I wanted to start
with a quick statement
from Robert Enslin,
our head of sales.
"This statement
really summarizes
one of our main goals
for Google Cloud.
We believe that your
cloud experience should
be easy, simple, and pleasant.
The best infrastructure
experience
is the one that shouldn't
require extensive research
and analysis before each step.
Thus, we interview the easiest
cloud for the enterprise.
And Google Compute
Engine is no exception."
With that in mind,
we'll be taking you
through the different
ways that we're
making our VM offering
simple and seamless for you.
At its core, Compute
Engine lets you easily
create, provision, and
run virtual machines
on Google's infrastructure.
You can create a
VM, choose between
predefined or pre-configured
machine types,
or create your own
custom machine shapes.
You can also leverage our
recommendations platform,
and you can leave a lot of
the operational overhead
to us with capabilities
such as live migration.
You can also automatically
save money with sustained use
discounts and even enjoy
deeper savings when you sign up
for committed use discounts.
Our focus today will
be on the first two
pillars of this experience,
the ones that are
under VM types on this chart.
So why is this important?
It's important
simply because you
will see that Compute Engine
is foundational to almost
everything you do in the cloud.
It's foundational to the
applications you want to run,
to the success of your
digital transformation,
as well as the modernization of
your data center and your cloud
operations.
And because of that, we believe
that your infrastructure
matters.
This makes it important
for us to make sure
that Compute Engine is the
right decision for your business
when it comes to providing
the right resources
in a comprehensive
and flexible way that
accelerates your innovation.
Compute Engine provides you with
the right business decisions
to deliver the right
resources to your teams
with simple, transparent,
and fair pricing;
the tools to optimize
cloud spend and pay
for what you use,
and nothing more;
also, the reliability
and security you
need to run your mission
critical applications.
Compute Engine also tries
to offer you everything
that you need.
Everything that you need
to digitize your business
so that you can
choose your resources
based on business requirements
with the flexibility
to adapt as your
workload changes.
You can get access to a variety
of predefined and customizable
VM families.
Coupled with flexible
consumption models,
you can configure
your machine types
for best fit and
optimal performance.
Right sizing helps you
get the best balance
for performance and pricing.
And the wide variety
of VM families
helps you get the
tailored support
for your diverse
computing needs.
Our VMs are designed
with all that in mind.
They are designed for
real world scenarios
so that you can run the
workloads you want in Google
Cloud and take advantage
of an optimized computing
infrastructure that provides
you with the right capabilities
for all your application
needs and helps you accelerate
your cloud transformation.
This can help you
get your scientists
in front of innovation, and
your data analysts in front
of insights, and your
mission critical applications
in front of your works force.
We do that by offering
virtual machine types that
fit the different types of
workloads you might be running.
Across our offering, we
focus on three key pillars
that you will see
me covering today.
The first one is that our
virtual machines will always
offer you leading
price performance
to ensure that you are running
your applications effectively
and efficiently, and that you
are seeing improvements year
over year.
We do that by leveraging
innovations across CPU vendors
and also by leveraging
unique Google technologies
that we've used
internally for years
to run our own infrastructure.
We also realize that your
workloads are not equal.
Some of them optimize
for high CPU performance,
while others focus
on high-end memory
configurations for business
critical databases.
You will see that our
offerings are optimized
for these different
requirements,
and they prioritize the needs
of the different applications.
The third pillar is that
we know that you don't
turn on just a virtual machine.
It's all about the
end-to-end experience
and the end-to-end capabilities
across networking, storage,
and compute, and
other capabilities
that make up your
infrastructure experience.
And because of
that, the offerings
we'll be discussing today
really cover the spectrum
and make sure that you can get
all the capabilities that you
need.
Our VM families, our
virtual machine types,
come in several shapes,
from general purpose
to workload optimized.
Starting on this
chart from the left,
you'll see that our general
purpose VMs are simple,
flexible, and the best fit for
the majority of your workloads.
E2 are our general
purpose VMs that
allow you to benefit
from deep savings,
up to 30% of our
general purpose pricing.
This family of VMs is
great for customers
who do not have application
dependencies on a specific CPU
architecture.
You simply pick that amount of
VCQ and memory that you want,
and we'll provision it for you.
We proactively adjust the
capacity for the entire fleet
to optimize
utilization, and that
means that we give you whichever
processor family is available.
Based on that, we
enable you to save a lot
by leveraging E2 VMs.
The second VM type that
we'll talk about today
is the family of general
purpose VMs, N2 and N2D.
These are our most
flexible VM types.
They offer leading
performance per dollar,
the latest CPU architectures
from both Intel and AMD,
and a wide range of
shapes and capabilities.
You can simply attach a lot of
other preferences to these VMs.
N2 and N2D are the
next generation
following N1 VMs, offering a
significant performance jump.
Now let's move to the
workload-optimized VMs.
Compute-optimized VMs
are the best fit VM type
for compute-intensive
workloads, including AAA gaming,
electronic design automation,
and high performance computing.
They are powered by
high-frequency Intel scalable
CPUs and offer approximately
40% higher performance compared
to other GC VMs.
Next on this list are
our memory-optimized VMs.
They are the best fit for
memory-intensive workloads,
including in-memory
databases like SAP
HANA, in-memory analytics,
and in-memory cache.
Memory optimized VMs offer the
highest memory configuration
available on GCP,
and they can be
configured with up to 12
terabytes of memory today.
Finally, we're working on a
new GPU optimize VM type, A2,
that will offer the
latest GPUs available
and will be available
later this year.
Now let's start going into
these different VM families,
and let us understand how they
fit your different application
requirements.
We'll start with the
general purpose VMs,
and we'll start with E2.
For general purpose workloads
that prioritize cost savings,
E2 VMs offer up to 31%
savings compared to N1 VMs,
on both lists and
commitments pricing.
This makes them the lowest
total cost of ownership, or TCO,
offering available
in Google Cloud.
They are a great
choice for web servers,
small to medium databases,
dev and test environments,
and many applications that
don't have strict performance
requirements.
They offer a compatible
performance baseline
to the current N1
VMs for those of you
who have been using them.
E2 VMs are available
with up to 16 vCPUs
and 128 gigabytes of memory.
And they also support
flexible configurations
through custom machine
types that enable you
to rightsize your resources.
Some constraints you
should be aware of
is that E2 VMs run
on any available CPU
in our infrastructure,
across Intel and AMD.
They also run across older and
more recent CPU generations.
You cannot select your CPU.
These VMs do not
offer you the ability
to attach local storage or GPUs.
However, they benefit from
dynamic resource management,
which is an efficient
scheduling mechanism that
enables us to give you only
the resources you need,
and leverage like
migration to move you
to a server host
with more resources
as your application
asks for more.
This Google technology
brings you a lot of benefits,
as long as you have a
flexible workload that
can benefit from these
resource constraints.
To assess the benefits
to your workload,
you can look at the
potential performance
per dollar improvements
shown on this slide.
We're showing here
examples of some benchmarks
and how they leverage
the E2 cost savings.
For example, you can
see approximately 30%
higher throughput per dollar
for webserving workloads.
The same benefits are
also available when
looking at benchmarks that
represent app and dev testing.
For workloads that could
benefit from these improvements,
E2 also offers a large
list of upcoming features
that you can look forward to.
We are continuing to expand
the capabilities of E2 VMs
with new features that include
making them generally available
in more GCP regions, making
them leverage AMD CPUs, as well
as Intel CPUs, in
more locations.
And also for the
first time offering
committed use discounts
for shared core
smaller VMs, so
that you can even
get more economic benefits.
And finally, we're
continuing to look
at new machine types
that would expand
the available
configurations, too.
Now let's move to
N2 and N2D VMs.
These VMs are the best
fit for a majority
of your general
purpose workloads,
as they prioritize flexibility
and offer leading price
performance.
N2 and N2D VMs are a great
fit for your enterprise
applications, databases,
and many of your web
and app serving workloads.
They are also our most
flexible VM offering.
They give you a
wide feature set,
enabling granular control of
your resources and coverage
across capabilities that
range from sole tenancy
to the flexibility to add and
remove storage at any point,
for example.
General purpose
N2 and N2D VMs are
designed to support a
variety of workloads
by offering a perfect balance
of compute and memory resources
with up to 200 vCPUs and
800 gigabytes of memory.
Flexibility is really a core
priority and a differentiator
for this VM family.
Our VMs, or virtual
machines, under N2 and N2D
enable you to rightsize
your resources, which
is a great cost-saving feature.
They also enable you to auto
upgrade to new CPU generations
as we launch the latest
architectures in the market.
This means that you can simply
choose a minimum CPU platform,
and Google will automatically
run your VM on the latest CPU
generations.
You can attach up
to nine terabytes
of local storage per node.
And you can get the highest
networking performance
with 32 gigabits per second.
These VMs are also being
rolled out globally
across all of our Google
Compute Engine regions.
Thinking about the key
differences between N2 and N2D
VMs, you can see an overview
summarized over here.
N2 VMs are our general
purpose Intel VMs,
supporting the latest second
generation scalable processor
from Intel with up to 80 vCPUs.
They come with approximately 20
to 30 performance improvements,
giving you a great price
performance benefit
over the older generations.
N2D are our AMD-based
general purpose VMs.
They leverage the
latest Epyc Rome CPUs,
and they come with up
to 224 vCPUs per node.
They even offer
you a lower price
point, with approximately
13% lower pricing
versus comparable VMs.
Now let's move to
some benchmarks
and show you how you can benefit
from our latest general purpose
VMs.
Over here, you can
see a wide range
of benchmarks
showing improvements
that range from 25% to 30%
for most workload types.
You can see that N2 VMs
show great improvements when
looking at benchmarks
like SAPBenchmarkDB,
for example, which represents
high-end databases.
And over there we can see
30% higher SAPs compared
to comparable VM types.
When we look at the benchmarks
like Chromium Complie,
you can see that you're
achieving approximately 25%
improvement in little time--
a great example of
the benefits that you
can see with N2 VMs for
many of your applications.
Now let's look at some
benchmarks for N2D.
As you can see, there
are many benefits
that we can see when looking
at data management workloads,
given that these leverage
AMD's higher memory
bandwidth and higher
persistent throughput,
which is available with
the larger VM shapes.
We've actually seen up to
2x performance improvements
for some workloads,
like video streaming,
which are represented here
through the stream benchmark.
And they show how
this higher memory
bandwidth can be
of great benefit
to many of your workloads.
So in summary, N2 and N2D
VMs offer a wide range
of capabilities and
also have a rich roadmap
as we think about
the capabilities
that we're bringing
into these VM types.
Features that we're working on
range from bare metal instances
to higher networking
performance,
with up to 100
gigabytes per second.
We're also working on
bringing you the latest CPU
platforms across
both Intel and AMD,
and you will see
those continuing
to come very quickly to
these instance types.
Now that we've covered the
general purpose VMs, let's move
to some of our
workload-optimized VM families.
We'll start with
compute-optimized VMs.
Performance-sensitive and
compute-bound workloads
come in many shapes and forms.
They might be high performance
interactive web servers,
AAA games, high performance
computing across simulations,
genomic analysis, or
media transcoding.
They might also be
applications that
have very expensive
per core licensing
and thus would benefit from
higher per core performance.
All of these applications
have one thing in common.
They would see great advantages
from leveraging the higher
per core performance and the
fastest CPUs you can give them.
And this is where
compute-optimized VMs
can really supercharge
your applications.
The compute-optimized VMs are
one of our latest additions
to the Google Compute Engine
virtual machine portfolio.
They offer the latest CPUs--
Intel scalable
processors, Cascade Lake.
They offer the highest
frequency per core
available on Google
Compute Engine,
with up to 3.8 gigahertz.
And they offer multiple
shapes that go from four vCPUs
to 60 vCPUs.
They also enable you to attach
local storage, if that's
needed by your application,
and offer you up
to 32 gigabits per second
networking bandwidth.
With capability such as
NUMA-aware performance
and higher performance
per threat,
as well as higher isolation for
latency sensitive workloads,
these VMs can offer you a great
boost for many applications.
Looking at how this
can benefit you,
let's look at some of
the benchmarks over here.
These benchmarks represent both
highly interactive applications
and high performance
computing workloads.
The results are evident.
All of them see approximately
40% to 41% performance
improvements.
This can see over here in the
increase in the average queries
per second and also the
decrease in the average runtime
seen under Open FOAM.
With these benefits
in mind, we also
wanted to share with you some
of the capabilities we're
adding to the compute-optimized
VMs over the next few months.
These include bare metal
instances support, as well as
an increase in networking
performance with 100 gigabits
per second coming soon.
As we've mentioned for
the general purpose VMs,
we're also always looking at
the latest CPU innovations
so that we can always
offer you improving
price performance as you utilize
some of these VM capabilities.
The second family under
our optimized VM types
is memory-optimized VMs.
Memory-optimized VMs are
designed for high-end business
critical applications
and specifically SAP.
They are a great fit
for in-memory databases
like SAP HANA,
in-memory analytics,
and in-memory persistent cache.
They offer you
the highest memory
per core available on Google
Compute Engine and the lowest
price per gig of memory as well.
They feature the latest and
fastest memory technologies
and come in
different shapes that
range from one terabyte
of memory per node per VM,
up to 12 terabytes per node,
which is really enough memory
to run your most
memory-intensive applications.
In addition to the shapes and
capabilities of these VMs,
they are also optimized for
flexibility and simplicity.
For example, capabilities
like live migration
helps you minimize
downtime, even
as you run workloads
that require
12 terabytes of data in memory.
We can take away a
lot of the overhead
for operating those VMs.
They also come with
flexible commitments
across all the memory
optimized shapes,
so that they can continue to
grow with you as your data
size grows.
A great example of that
is illustrated over here
when we look at
some of the customer
case studies for our customers
who have been using those VMs
and referencing one of the
testimonials we've seen.
We've seen customers with
9 terabytes of SAP data
that is growing approximately
at 1 terabyte per year.
So for them to be
able to leverage
our flexible commitments and
the many sizes we offer simply
means that they can maintain
support for their data size
as it grows on our platform.
If you have workloads that
would benefit from these memory
configurations and would benefit
from the memory-optimized VMs,
you also have a
lot of capabilities
to look forward to.
Some of the capabilities
that are coming soon
to our memory-optimized VMs
include higher networking
and storage
performance, as well as
additional SAP certifications.
And of course, newer CPU
platforms and additional
shapes so that you can
always rightsize your VM
to the requirements
of your applications
and your databases.
Now that we've given you a
quick overview of all of the VM
families and virtual machine
capabilities available on GCP,
we wanted to leave you with
a few statements on how
to best get started with
these virtual machine types.
So for your workloads
that would benefit
from the memory-optimized
VMs, we also
have a very rich roadmap
that you can look forward to.
This includes networking
and storage performance
improvements.
We're looking at 100
gig enhanced networking
capabilities, as well
as new capabilities
under extreme storage,
extreme persistent disk, that
would bring you the
highest storage performance
for these large VMs.
We're also looking at
more SAP certifications
so that you can
run more workloads
on these virtual machines.
And as always, we're looking at
newer CPU platforms, as well as
additional shapes, so that you
can always rightsize your VM
and leverage only the
resources that you truly need,
minimizing waste.
Now that we've taken you
through all of our VM types
and families, we
wanted to leave you
with a quick guide
for how to get started
with these different VM
types and these different VM
families.
We look at this as a
simple three-step process.
For the first step, consider
your resource specs.
What are the shapes
and resources
needed by your applications?
How sensitive are you to
specific CPUs architectures?
You, for example, need to use
something like Intel AVX 512,
and need to make sure that
you're running on CPUs
that have this capability.
Do you need to qualify
every new CPU architecture,
or are you more
flexible in terms
of the underlying hardware?
After you've thought
about that, we
would recommend that
you start thinking
about price performance.
Which of your
applications would benefit
from higher performance?
Which of your applications
are highly interactive when
you need the shortest
runtime and the best
latency for example?
That would be one
category of applications
that would benefit from our
highest-performant compute
instances, like
compute-optimize VMs.
On the other side, what
are the applications
that would be a great fit
for additional cost savings?
Over there, we'd recommend
that you look at VM types
like E2 VMs, for example,
that can give you
a lot of cost savings.
So once you've had a chance
to look at your resource specs
and look at your pricing
and performance priorities,
now it's time to think
about deployment planning.
As you think about
your deployment plan,
we would recommend you start
looking at your capacity
requirements and
looking at the regions
where you want to
be running your VMs.
You can also find a lot of
resources on our Google Compute
Engine documentation
pages that can guide you
through the migration process.
This concludes our overview
of the Google Compute Engine
virtual machine types
introduction today.
We hope that it was
useful and that you
have a lot of information
to get started with.
Thank you so much for
being with us today.
That's all for today.